John Keats lived to be only twenty six years old yet he is one of our greatest
English
poets. My guest today is Miss Eileen Ward who has written a fascinating
study of this brief and passionate life in title. John
Keats the making of a poet her work recently received the National Book Award
for Arts and Letters. This war there's been many studies of Keeton as poetry.
Why another book on Keats.
That's a question that I asked myself a number of times in the course of writing this
book I could answer it very simply by saying
that year by year scholars turn up interesting new facts
about teats critics come out with new critical assessments
of him but none of these add up
to a new full length portrait of Keats and this was what
I wanted to try. We haven't had full length biography of Keats
for some twenty five years now it seems already
to represent a rather old fashioned point of view.
What exactly did you mean when you wrote that Keith's life shows a
significant completion the achievement of identity the self making art.
This is
the this is the rule of focus of
my reinterpretation of Keats so far as I tried to give a
new portrait. I was first
struck when I was reading the
letters carefully by the word that he uses over and over again identity is
something that first of all he has a sense of not having He wrote several
rather extraordinary letters to the effect that the poet has no identity.
He's the most an poetical of all characters in existence.
And then later in his career he speaks of this sense of identity as
something that is very. For him to achieve.
About this time I read. Erick Erickson's.
Central book childhood in society in which he works out a very interesting theory
of identity as something that the young person
particularly around twenty
is especially concerned to achieve and I wondered whether Keats's use of the
term identity was related in any way to Ericsson's and the more I thought about it the
more these seem to play into one another.
And this then emerged as one of the central themes of my own
book would need by definition any artist have to find his own identity.
Yes not only
any artist I think but really every young person as he cut some self
or from that family as he finishes his schooling as he faces
adult life for the first time there is
a tremendous inner need to define oneself
in relation to the world at large is an independent being but I think it's a
particularly crucial problem with the artist because his art in some
ways is simply the projection of his identity into his
chosen
medium and we
can see certainly more clearly perhaps in the work of a writer
than any other artist what all the problems of
defining
the self. First of all and then projecting it into the art
that expresses it could you describe that identity
which keeps sound.
Well to borrow a cue from Erickson he suggests that every child in growing
up goes through a number of identifications.
With the significant adults in his environment.
People whom he admires and who he tries to pattern himself on so that
when he finally emerges as a. A person in his own right.
Say at the beginning of his twenty's.
Many of those previous identifications or tentative identities
are caught up in and harmonized in the mature identity which is something
of
the whole which is more than the sum of its parts. Now I think that there
are three roles three identifications we can see
in Keats as he grew up the first.
Was very strong identification with an uncle of his who
was a captain in the Marines and especially after the death of keeps
his father he served as the pattern of the man that keeps wanted to
be and we know from his school days how he had a great reputation
for courage
and Cuban acidy seems to be modeling himself on
the hero. If he wanted to be then at the age of fifteen
he had to decide on his career and he chose the profession of
medicine which is always astonished Keats's readers at
first glance and I think this
is another very essential aspect to keep his character a kind
of self adding the gating side
very tender and sympathetic. Side of his personality which
is very much concerned with
helping the world with relieving the suffering of
mankind and then at the time so
about when you turn twenty one when he gave up medicine for poetry.
His first character as a poet. I think was very strongly modeled on identification with
Lee Hunt who was the
first really great influence among the living poets on him what was the
one likely kind of your wellies hunt is very easy to make fun of he
was something of a dilettante something of a poser. And who had a
rather
superficial conception of poetry as a thing of luck
Joria sensations and sentimental.
Situations and this brought out a great deal of
the worst of Keats's early poetic make of
the little incident which I think precipitated Keith's
break with is rather characteristic. Hunt always
like sonnet writing contests and one evening he suggested to Keats that
they make themselves a laurel crowns like the ancient poets
and sit with these crowns on their heads and write sonnets
on what they
felt and Keats did it immediately afterward had a
strong revulsion against all that kind of posturing as a poet.
And he said there's
no greater sin after the seven deadly than to fool yourself
into the idea of being a great poet. So with this break with
Hunt the early character of the poet that he had assumed was
I think submerged or shrugged off and I think we can see in
the year
that followed something rather extraordinary
happening. Which can be traced in the end a jury of his poetry a
great many images of his poetic career
as
a journey of exploration across uncharted seas.
Or as a battle as a great exploit like climbing a
mountain come out and I feel that this shows something of the sense of the
heroic endeavor that was part of
the sense of himself he
got from identification with his naval uncle then
still more gradually there's another element that enters into his poetry and that is. As
you describe. That in the fall of Hyperion the poet as physician to all
men. And the primary responsibility of the poet
he sings is to take on the sufferings of the world to face them
and somehow or other to present them to mankind in a way that they
can meet and
reconcile themselves to so gradually I think we see all these
three previous elements of his personality merging
into harmony which is the mature kids.
Didn't Keats in his poetry triumph over the tragic events of his life.
I
feel he did I think this is another one of the extraordinary It seems
that we can trace in his life as it illuminates his poetry. There are
a number
of minor themes in his poetry that are interesting
to isolate there's a great deal of concern with sickness and
health noticeable in his imagery. There's also a scene that
recurs a number of times in his poetry it changes each
time he presents it but it is either that of the
dead
awakening or of. A beautiful and beloved woman caught just
at the moment that she dies and
the look of recognition fades from her eyes. This.
I think is very closely related to what we know was the
central emotional experience of teachers life and that is the death of his mother when he was
fourteen he was very deeply devoted to his
mother and during her last illness of tuberculosis.
He used to take the part of nursing her and he cooked
her meals or gave her medicine he read to her he watched all night by her bedside.
And I think that this
memory of. Or dying.
And then
the kind of dream one often has afterward
of the dead person coming to life again is
quite an interesting clue to this constant thing the minimum
or this is the dead coming to life living dying that
we find throughout his poetry in so far you as he was able to face that and
transmute it I think he
did achieve his
own task of being physician to all men as he called
the poet.
So the conflict between being a doctor and doing tangible good for
humanity and then making beautiful verses which certainly has
no manifest indirect benefit was resolved in his mind. I think so
in so far as the most
beautiful most during the greatest of his
poetry is always consumed with this theme of the
inevitable suffering and death of human
experience and how does one come to terms with it.
To what degree do you feel Keats. Reached an identity and achieve
good at what point in his like did this come.
This of course is a matter of speculation but
I feel that that letter to his brother
George of April eighteen nineteen in which he describes in some detail.
The process of what he calls soul making of finding an
identity. Is as clear an indication that he had reached.
This goal which previously he thought he as a poet
would never attain this means I think that he came
to terms with the suffering with the uncertainties
with the inevitable limitations of his. Own
life at about this time. We had only about eight more months in
which to write
poetry and not quite two more years to
live he didn't write anything after
he fell ill in February eight hundred
twenty he had finally committed himself to his love for Fanny
Brawne and was shouldering the responsibilities that
this involved chiefly of deciding how he
could make enough money to marry
her and this
meant to reconcile himself to the prospect of returning to medicine. It
was necessary giving up poetry. He gave himself. One more chance
the summer of eighteen nineteen to see whether he could break through and become a
successful poet and of course he
failed. But he was willing to take the risk knowing what was involved.
What was the nature of it teaches relationship to Fanny Brawne was it
ever one that was filled and
sustaining here again we have to
speculate some because Keats was
very reticent to tell anybody
about
this love affair and the only thing we have to go on
are is his letters to Fanny Brawne.
Not all of which either have survived.
She was a young lady of good
family. Which meant of course that she had a mother who was
concerned that she make a good
match and I don't think Keith was ever comfortable in the row
of fiancé. There's been a great deal of speculation about whether
she was even the right woman for him. I think she was she had a tremendous amount
of vitality and this was what Keats was essentially
looking for a girl with a fire. In her heart like mine
as he described it once she was very beautiful at least so Keats
thought and this mattered
tremendously to him she was also quite intelligent as we can
gather from her own letters to keep his younger sister Sandy Keats
and more than that I think she had extraordinary insight
into human beings great courage great command over her
own emotions which comes out. Really magnificently during the months and keeps
his illness and following his death so far as
the satisfactions of their love affair I don't think there were very
many he was kept on probation for a long time
to prove whether he could in fact support
her. I'm sure that the physical
contact between them was something fairly rigorously chaperoned the worst
thing in the whole terrible exile from England was
leaving Fanny as he said to Brown in a letter after he
left. I should have had her when I was unhealthy and I should have
remained Well I can bear to die I cannot bear to leave her.
He seemed to resist his love for her for in the in the early stages when I
was as
well. Keats had several reasons for
being quite wary in his relations with women one of them he was
very keenly aware of and that was his short height. Remembering
that people
were shorter then than they are today still
he was only five foot one and that put him at a
real disadvantage with most women he felt that he
was physically insignificant. And that no woman he
ever loved could quite love him in the same
degree. He also had. Suspicion which comes
out in several extraordinary letters he wrote on the subject there was something not quite
right in his feelings about women and this had its roots deep
in his
past. For us today it's very easy to see how
this was related to his feelings about his
mother keep his father died when he was only eight suddenly in an accident
and she waited less than two months to
remarry. And I don't think we need to
be trained psychologist to know what a shock that
was to a boy of eight then that second marriage was a
failure and Mrs Keats went off then this is Jennings in mysterious disgrace
for several years. And did not return to her
family until she was already
ill so that Keats had
very mixed feelings about her this great
love this anger at her betraying him
and leaving him and then of course the overwhelming experience he had
of nursing her in her last illness and not being able to save
her and I think that that sense
that loving a woman was really a very dangerous thing never quite
left him.
You can never quite trust. A woman and particularly a
woman like Sandy Braun who seems in many ways to resemble his
mother fellow vitality loving
pleasure and beautiful as
it seems keeps his mother also was this I think we can
understand may have been the one of the sources
of her attraction for him in the first
place with all of the difficulties that Keats faced his
parents dying financial insecurity undersell love. Fanny
Brawne Did he ever doubt himself as a poet.
This is a really interesting question. He had to battle his way up.
As a poet first before he was even recognized by Hunt.
Not at all sure that he had it in the him to become a
poet with the writing say of the sonnet on chap and Homer
which everyone realized immediately was a really great sonnet. Then
I think the possibility of future
achievement became really Actual to him
and even though the first little volume of poems published in eight
hundred seventeen was a failure.
He still felt that he could do
something great in any and and I think it was an extraordinary shock to
him that he fell so far below his own aspirations in that
poem and then the reviewers should have slaughtered it so
immersive fully but he had enough
belief in himself to go on writing as he
said at the time starting Hyperion which was also the time that the
terrible reviews of Endymion came out I think I shall be among the English poets after my
death. Recognition would come in time of the terrible
thing is that as his
illness advanced and his third volume of poems came
out with the unfinished Hyperion in it he came to suspect
that he hadn't achieved anything. That he had hoped
to that he would simply be remembered as the protege of.
Leigh Hunt's the pet lamb in a sentimental force as he called it.
And in his last months he wanted completely to be forgotten as a
poet you think this is result of his own self doubts or of the. The extremely
critical reviews that he had been receiving are combination.
Probably a combination I think he was emotionally vulnerable to the
reviews in his illness if he had not been during his
health
but what he says in a very beautiful and
moving letter to
Fanny a month or two after his
illness began.
If I should die said I to myself I have left no immortal work behind me
nothing to make my friends proud of my name but I have
loved the principle of beauty in all things and if I had had
time I would have made myself
remembered then
I think he lost that stoic sense
of resignation and
who is a failure and it was in the
last month or two as he was dying in Rome that he asked his friend
Severn that his name not been grave on his tombstone as
it is
not simply the words after a long preface Here
lies one whose name is written in water.
And he wanted no notice of this death put in the newspapers no
engraving made of any portrait of me wanted his name completely to be forgotten.
How was he to take for his literary reputation to establish itself
more than twenty years he died in eight hundred twenty one in the first full
length biography came out in eighteen forty eight and this was the thing
that rescued Keats from oblivion. But it did seem
for the two decades after his death of his own prophecy
was going to be realized that he would be completely
forgotten within his many friends and acquaintances and the intellectuals of the time really
didn't serve much to help his reputation. Kept
alive no unfortunately keeps was still identified as
the protege of hunt in the minds of the public
and this meant that people were not only suspicious
of his poetry is being a kind of poetry they really couldn't understand
or couldn't approve of.
But they were also suspicious of his political
principles and my news acquaintances were people like Hazlitt Woods worse and Shelley.
What do you feel he learned from his contemporaries What influence did they have of poetry.
He learned a great deal from Wordsworth even
though when he got to know Wordsworth personally he had quite
a dismal losing experience. Words with by that time with middle
aged reactionary.
Egocentric and seemed in every way different from
the ideal poet who Keats had imagined him to be.
I think it's a. Testimony to keep his generosity of
spirit and he was able to rise above
that personal experience and
to reaffirm his belief that Wordsworth was the greatest
poet of the times with Shelley and afraid there was a
temperamental difference from the start that was just about completely unbridgeable.
Shelley unconsciously patronised
Keats and Keats in his pride reacted very strongly against
that I think Keats also had a sense that they were very
different in their poetic games and practices.
Has led is the chief electoral
influence Keats and many
of Keats is
really searching
meditation's life on poetry can be traced
back to. Some. Original
intellectual stimulus from Hazlitt for instance that term identity
which enters into Keats's
letters at many points and gradually emerges as one of his very
central preoccupations is a term that he borrowed from Hazlitt's philosophy though
he does use it in a very significantly different way from has let
himself miswired what place do you feel keep tolls in English letters.
I think that.
As long ago as one hundred twenty one the hundred anniversary of. Keep his death
he had one in everybody's estimation a central place in
English poetry as Matthew Arnold had said I think it was eight hundred eighty.
He is he is with
Shakespeare. Perhaps this is claiming too much for a poet
who really died as his career was just beginning. I think that
Shakespearean quality that Arnold claimed for Keats is something we
do recognize even though.
Keats never had the fully
rounded creative career that Shakespeare did and
I think it's significant that during the years since nine hundred twenty
one as romantic poetry has gone under a critical cloud keeps
was one poet who remained unquestioned
as a great craftsman a great poet and I think
the contribution of the new critics to our reading of Keats is
to make us more fully aware than ever
before of
the very great art of his poetry as
well as of course the essential heroism of the
spirit is what I wonder what you feel the relevance of the life of
a genius is to those of us who are not great artists.
I think the
story of how Keats. Discovered his the location.
And made himself into a poet is one with
great meaning for all of
us whether we have ever longed to be creative person or
not that sense of coming to terms with one's self.
That is involved in this achievement of identity of
realizing what one's past has been what one's unrealised
potentiality still are what can be
done to
take these. Givens and these possibilities
of one's own life and work them together into.
Significant
envision significant achievement.
This is something that everybody in some measure or other must
face in his own life is a
challenge and the story of how Keats met that challenge in
his own life. I think is a heroic
deeply moving and meaningful one for us all is what I want
to thank you
very much for your book on Keats and for this interview.